[Music]
hi my name is Molly I live in Los
Angeles this is my apartment
I pay $1,400 a month come inside I'll
show you around
hi my name is Kayla I live just outside
of downtown Atlanta in a two-bedroom
two-bath apartment for about 14 under
[Music]
alright this is my apartments first
we're gonna start with the kitchen I
would say my style is more so creative I
hate white walls with a passion I'm like
why not decorate and love the place she
lives this is my like clock walk one
time I went to like Z Gallerie and may
have just had this nice like flooded
spot and so I kind of stole the idea
from there and I just got these from
like different stores and like this
place don't you
this is my muse I have a dishwasher
thank God because I hate washing dishes
a fridge my kind of admin space thank
God because they are flooded with food
and all these other things this is my
kitchen it doesn't have a lot to it
there's no dishwasher it's got
everything I need then we tried to like
dress it up by adding more wallpaper and
it didn't come with a pantry so we built
this ourselves
all right so this is my dining room here
I love it but I also hate it
I love these three pictures here but I
feel like I just rushed and bought them
because I couldn't find anything else to
throw in the wall I like them they're
okay but I feel like they would be
better in like a kid's room you know
these little baby animals blue my dining
room tables I got it off Craigslist for
about $50 I kind of want to do one but
it definitely does the trick for now it
seats about four and then I pull my two
decorative chairs over and then it'll
seat about six people okay so this is my
living room
and anytime I go to a like a flea market
or anything I find like the one gold
thing and I buy it and I'm obsessed with
it so send gold things my way the best
part is is I can do whatever I want to
and my landlord doesn't care so we put
up wallpaper removable hoop into the
wall I love to do in here is you watch
her on a TV you lay on our giant couch
my wife likes to drink wine cheese plate
I blew it took about a day and a half to
paint the wall because I didn't have
like the right tools so there was a
painting ceiling there's paint on the
carpet there was just paint everywhere
the wall here was just literally like a
brain explosion it's just like I put
this I don't know I want to put this up
I would put this so I was like I'm just
gonna put it all whatever I so the best
part is try
it's huge we have a full couch out here
we have a grill table it's really nice
cuz la has got the best weather so this
patio is probably my least favorite part
about the apartment just because it's a
little small but I mean it's still okay
as you can see there's nothing really
out here but it does have a nice view at
night it just lights up and there's
building then just light up everywhere
over there and it's actually quite nice
this is my house it and you can see I
have way too many clothes I have way too
many bags way too many shoes this closet
is big but it's just not big enough for
me
this is my bathroom yeah you can get to
it straight from the closet the color
scheme is kind of like not really
existent but I put blue there's a nice
little shower curtain ooh there's little
pops of color everywhere you have
Marilyn Monroe so you just can't go
wrong with that okay so this is the rest
room it's kind of small but we've added
our own shelving this is the typical la
bathroom I think here is our bedroom
which is this pretty nice size it's
beautiful like it looks out to the hills
it's got a huge closet space and this is
my bedroom this is where the magic
happens
just kidding this is where I come and
crash every day after work because I'm
exhausted these are my two little
nightstands I love them so much one of
them I just used for lecture
I just draw all my jewelry over here
there's not really not really any
organization to live my I like it over
here this is my little cute nightstand
as you can see I usually keep little
photos of me and my girlfriend here
whenever we take these we have like a
million of these from everywhere I just
haven't done up however it's suddenly
decorated but no one really sleeps in
here like that unless I have like
company come over unless I'm charging
someone like oh you can stay here for a
month for this price thank God I have a
washer and a dryer ours didn't come with
it but I had to purchase everything
individually so this is my poor area
it's very nice size and spacious it's
actually closed today which is a
I'm a degenerate and I lost to keep get
in it ah so that's when $1400 can get
you in Los Angeles a spacious living
room a huge bedroom with a view and a
spectacular terrace alright guys well
thanks for checking out my apartment now
you see what $1400 can get you in
Atlanta a beautiful kitchen space two
bedrooms that are equally spacious a gym
a pull everything you could ever imagine
thanks for coming come on Yeah right
thanks for joining
now you gotta go bye hallo Hey
unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're part subscribe here that was my
part